hello everyone welcome to part two in
our series on supervised sentiment
analysis this screencast is going to
focus on some general practical tips for
doing work in this space especially
focused on
setting up a project and doing kind of
pre-processing of your data
so first i just wanted to give you links
to a whole bunch of benchmark data sets
in this space we're going to concentrate
on the sst and dynacent but there are a
lot of other choices you could make both
for developing original systems and also
supplementing training data that you've
got for a particular application some of
these data sets are really really large
and they cover a diversity of domains so
these could be important assets for you
in a similar spirit there are lots of
sentiment lexicons out there they cover
different emotional dimensions and
different aspects of the problem and
they too could be used to help you with
powerful featurization they could
supplement features that you've created
or help you group your vocabulary into
interesting subcategories that would be
powerful for making sentiment
predictions and these range from simple
wordless up to highly structured
multi-dimensional lexicons
now for our first pre-processing step i
thought we would just talk a little bit
about tokenization because i think that
this can be a definitional choice that
really affects downstream success so
just as a running example here let's
imagine we start with this raw text
which is a kind of imagined tweet
we have an at mention here and then you
can see that some of the markup has
gotten a little bit garbled we have an
emoticon that looks sort of obscured in
a link at the end
i think as a very preliminary step even
before we tokenize we might want to
isolate some of that markup and replace
the html entities it's a pretty easy
thing that you can do that could really
make a difference now we've got our
apostrophe we've got our emoticon intact
and then we still have the link and
other things in here
so even before you do that you might
check to see whether a simple
replacement of the html entities would
make a difference in your data
now we begin the tokenization question
and i think a good baseline choice here
would be simply white space tokenizing
we're going to split on white space and
treat all the resulting strings as
tokens so that would take our raw text
up here and split it up as as you can
see on these independent lines
this looks okay to me so we're going to
have a problem with our at mention
because it has this colon on the end so
we might miss the fact that this is the
actual at mention the unigrams look okay
although the date has been split apart
we've preserved our hashtag we've got
this token that might appear only once
even though there's a clear consistent
signal there we do have our emoticon and
our link is mostly intact although this
period could be disruptive if we
actually want to follow the link because
it's still glommed onto the end of the
url
tree bank tokenizing is another very
common scheme in nlp i would say at this
point largely for historical reasons the
way tree bank tokenizing works is it
takes this raw text and splits it up
into a whole lot of tokens right in
comparison with white space we have a
lot of distinct pieces here and this
really looks kind of problematic right
so we have destroyed our at mention we
don't have that username anymore
it does this interesting thing with
words like can't that they get split
apart into two tokens
we've lost our date we have lost our
hashtag
this is possibly good so yay has been
split up according to its punctuation so
we have now four exclamation marks uh
separated out from this word here
but our emoticon is completely lost and
our link has been really destroyed so
this looks problematic from the point of
view of accurate featurization and also
doing things with social media
so that kind of brings me to what we
might want from what i've called a
sentiment-aware tokenizer we would like
to isolate emoticons clearly because
they can be really sentiment-laden
we want to probably respect twitter and
other domain specific markup because
that's often the space in which our in
our data come from and the kind of place
we want to make predictions in
in a similar spirit you might take
advantage of underlying markup maybe
don't filter off the html because there
could be an important signal there
you might be aware that the website or
data producer might have done some
pre-processing of their own that might
disrupt things like curses which could
of course carry a lot of important
important sentiment information
you might want to preserve
capitalization because of course that
could be used for emphasis
uh in a similar spirit you might want to
regularize emotive lengthening like yay
down to just three characters here to
capture that it is an emotive
lengthening but also regularize all
those distinct tokens
and then as a stretch goal although this
might be less important in the era of
contextual models you might think about
capturing multi-word expressions that
carry sentiment just think of an example
like out of this world which is positive
but none of its component pieces are
positive so many models will miss that
that is conveying clear sentiment
whereas with a clever tokenization
scheme you might capture that as one
single token
so here's a simple example uh that meets
a lot of those goals here for a set of
aware tokenizer we begin from our usual
raw text we normalize and preserve the
at mention
we keep most of these words intact and
we kind of capture that that june 9
thing was a date
preserve the hashtag of course
we're treating all of these potentially
emotion-laden punctuation marks as
separate unigrams i think that could be
good
of course capture the emoticon and
capture the link
and if you want something that meets
more or less all these criteria except i
think the date normalization you could
just use the nltk tweet tokenizer it's a
good simple choice that you could make
that i think will be useful for
sentiment analysis and to quantify that
a little bit here's a some experimental
evidence that i think is going to be
relevant to the kind of work that you
all are doing
so my data is open table that's
restaurant reviews short ones
i've got 6 000 reviews in my test set
and what i'm doing along the x axis here
is varying the amount of training data
that these systems can see
it's simply a softmax classifier and my
primary manipulation is i have the
sentiment aware tokenizer in orange
treebank in green and whitespace in gray
and the picture is pretty clear right
along the x-axis we have accuracy it's a
balanced problem
and what you can see is that the
sentiment aware tokenizer is the clear
winner here especially where training
data are sparse uh in the limit of
adding lots of training data i think we
can make up for a lot of shortcomings of
tokenizers because we see a lot of
redundancy in the training data
but where data are sparse the center
manual tokenizer is clearly a good
choice and another thing i would add is
that because it produces more intuitive
tokens the sentiment aware models might
be more interpretable in some sense
and to really connect with the homework
that you all are doing and the bake off
this is what happens when we go across
domains so here i'm training on open
table restaurant reviews but i'm going
to test on movie review sentences here
otherwise this is the same experimental
paradigm because of the cross domain
thing the results are a little bit more
chaotic but i think again the sentiment
aware tokenizer is a clear winner with
the largest gains where training data
are a little bit sparse and that's the
expected picture
so be thoughtful about tokenizing as a
counterpoint to that i've called this
section on stemming the dangers of
stemming because what i want to try to
do is convince you not to stem your data
but first what is stemming so stemming
is a kind of preprocessing technique
that would collapse collapse distinct
word forms there are three common
algorithms for this
easy to use the port or simmer the
lancaster stemmer and the wordnet
stemmer and my criticisms are largely
leveled at porter and lancaster
here is the bottom line
in doing this kind of stemming you are
apt to destroy many important sentiment
distinctions making this a
counterproductive pre-processing step
on the other hand the word netstemmer
does not have this problem
it's much more conservative but it also
doesn't really do enough to make it
worthwhile it's kind of costly to run it
has some requirements that might make it
simply not worth it and i would say that
the bottom line here for stemming is
that in an era where we have very large
sentiment data sets the function of
stemming would be to collapse the size
of your vocabulary and make learning
more easier in small domains but we
mostly don't confront that problem
anymore
but just to drive home this point here
here are some examples focused on the
port or stemmer of cases where running
the port or simmer actually collapses
clear sentiment distinctions according
to the harvard inquirer which is one of
those lexicons i mentioned before i've
got defense and defensive they get
collapsed down into this funny non-word
defense extravagance an extravagant
different sentiment collapse down into
this word fragment and so forth for
these other examples and i think this is
showing that in pre-processing your data
you might be removing some important
sentiment signals
the lancaster stemmer uses a very
similar strategy and has arguably even
more problems in this space here we've
got the positive word uh complement and
complicate
according to the harvard inquirer again
they could both get collapsed down into
what is a completely distinct word
comply
and that should be concerning for many
reasons and the other examples make a
very similar point
the word netstemmer i mentioned before i
think this actually has something going
for it uh there might be cases where
you'd want to use it it's high precision
it requires word part of speech pairs
and the general issue is just that it
removes some comparative morphology
that's the only thing you might worry
about for sentiment but otherwise it's
going to take like exclaims explained
and exclaiming and collapse them down
that could be a useful compression of
your feature space it will leave
exclamation alone which i think is good
similarly for these things they all kind
of get preserved across the two verb
forms but we preserve the adjective as
different i think that could be good and
as i said the only concern would be that
happy happier and happiest all go down
into their base form whereas i think
these could encode different gradations
of sentiment that you might want to
preserve
that's worth some thought but overall i
think you probably want to avoid doing
standing and to bring that home let's
return to my experimental paradigm using
a softmax classifier opentable reviews
6000 of them in my test set and here
along the x-axis i'm varying the amount
of training data i have
and i think what you see is that the
porter and lancaster stemmer and purple
and black respectively are kind of
forever behind right versus just simply
sentiment aware tokenizing it gives you
a lead
the lead is especially clear as you get
out of this very sparse domain here with
very few training instances
to close just a few other preprocessing
techniques that you might think about so
you could part a speech tied your data
in the spirit of trying to capture more
sentiment distinctions that you might
capture otherwise so just for example a
rest or like a resting as an adjective
is positive but a rest as a verb is
typically negative
um fine as an adjective is positive but
to incur a fine as a noun is negative
and so forth you can see that some
sentiment distinctions actually do turn
on the part of speech of the word so
treating all of your unigram features as
based in word part of speech tag pairs
could be useful for preserving some of
these distinctions again as a
pre-processing step to help your model
be more attuned to these points of
variation in comparison
but if there are limits even to this
right so this is just some cases on
these slides where even within the same
part of speech we have an adjective that
in one sense is positive and another
negative for example the adjective mean
can mean hateful but it can also mean
excellent as in uh they make a mean
apple pie
um
smart
as an adjective could be both painful uh
and also bright and brilliant and so
forth like that and similarly for
serious and fantastic and sneer
depending on the context and the
intention of the speaker they can kind
of cut in different directions um so
even part of speech tagging is going to
be limiting when it comes to really
recovering the underlying word sense
even for something as low dimensional as
a sentiment distinction
finally no this is another powerful
technique that you might use and think
about as you select and evaluate
different models this is what i've
called simple negation marking the
phenomenon is just that if i have a verb
like enjoy which sounds positive in
isolation
of course its contribution to the
overall sentiment will change depending
on whether it's in the scope of a
negation i didn't enjoy it as negative
and negation can be expressed in many
ways
as this modifier of auxiliaries like not
but as an adverb like never it could be
in the subject like no one and it could
even be really encode for things like i
have yet to enjoy it which is a kind of
negation
and then of course the negation in five
years very far i don't think i will
enjoy it is probably negative but the
negation is way far away uh from the
verb that we want to have that we want
whose sentiment we want to modulate with
the negation
so here's a very simple method that i
think was first exploited by explored by
dawson chen it's also used in peng at
all these are classic early sentiment
analysis papers and the idea is simply
to append a neg suffix to every word in
the sequence that appears between the
negation and some clause level mark of
punctuation to sort of roughly indicate
the semantic scope of the negation this
is a simple pre-processing step highly
heuristic it would take a sentence like
no one enjoys it and literally turn the
unigrams one and joys and it
into variant forms of them where one has
an egg appended to it and so does it
enjoys and so does it and the idea is
that in doing this we're giving our
model the opportunity to discover that
enjoys in this context is actually a
different token in some sense than
enjoys when it's not in the scope of
negation and for many of the linear
models with handout features that we
explore simply making that initial
distinction might create some space for
your model to learn the interaction of
negation with these other
features and just to quantify it a
little bit by way of rounding this out i
think this slide shows the impact that
this can have despite its simplicity so
similar we have open table as our test
set we're using a softmax classifier and
the x-axis is again varying the amount
of training data that we have
the white space tokenizer isn't gray
it's the worst followed by tree bank and
green
then we have that sentiment aware
tokenizer in orange
and then way above them consistently for
all parts of the data here are sentiment
aware plus that negation marking
that is obviously the superior model for
all kinds of amounts of training data
and i think what that's showing is that
the influence of negation is actually
really real and severe in a lot of
sentiment data sets it's just very
common to combine
sentiment words positive or negative
with negation and it has this
predictable effect of kind of flipping
the value
so in doing this sentiment and doing
this negation marking we're giving our
model a better chance at discovering
exactly those distinctions
and here's a similar set of results for
cross domain where i'm starting on open
table and testing on imdb again the
results are a little bit more chaotic
but i think it's a clear win for
the sentiment aware plus negation
marking model